a high-stakes congressional race will be
decided today in central Ohio
Republicans have controlled the 12th
district for more than 30 years now
Democrat Danny O'Connor is challenging
Republican Troy Ball derson both parties
see it as one last chance to make a
statement before the November midterm
elections Ed O'Keefe is following the
vote in Columbus Ohio
edie good morning good morning flat
bottom line Democrats shouldn't be
competitive in a congressional district
like this president Trump won here in
2016 but there's a 31 year old Democrat
keeping even with the Republican in a
race for an open house seat that the GOP
has held since the early 1980s let's go
win this thing Democrat Danny O'Connor
rallied his volunteers Monday he's
facing Republican state senator Troy
Ball derson from the entire race who's
earned endorsements from President Trump
and vice president pence there's only
one choice in this election that's vote
for Troy Bulger said the president urged
his supporters to turn out and attacked
O'Connor over the weekend
Danny O'Connor on his resume put stuff
that wasn't true he was like a low-level
person that did nothing but O'Connor
said he's not worried about mr. Trump's
involvement all these people parachuting
in from Washington DC they stayed for a
couple hours
they leave town they're not folks who
are going to our schools they're not
folks who were walking our streets
Trump's appearance caused a last-minute
headache for Baldr soon after Ohio
Governor John Kasich suggested that bald
erson didn't want the president's help I
said Troy why did you invite Trump in
here the president he said no I didn't
Alderson says Trump gave him a boost but
the president coming on Saturday help or
her huge help a lot of enthusiasm we
were around the district yesterday
that was a total conversation change the
rival campaign spent big money this
summer on ads let's fight back against
drug an insurance company greed liberals
and Washington want to repeal the
middle-class tax cuts but with momentum
on O'Connor's side his supporters think
a win by convincing some Republicans to
vote for him they're interested in a new
leadership in fresh energy Democrats
point out that this district is similar
to other parts of the country where they
think they can be competitive this
November President Trump won here by 11
points in 2016 so if Democrats somehow
pull it off tonight
it suggests we may be in for a bigger
blue wave than anticipated this fall
Gale both Republicans and Democrats
watching that tonight thank you very
much ad